next we have Ross bacon he's a
technologist who spent the majority of
his career helping create and scale
companies in Silicon Valley in 2015 Ross
accepted one-year appointment as a White
House presidential innovation fellow and
he worked to address various national
priorities through the lens of his
private sector experience after the
completion of his fellowship very
recently Ross joined Microsoft he's now
a senior advisor of technology and civic
innovation in New York City thank you
for the intro appreciate that so yes
very recently I finished my fellowship
in DC about a month ago and moved to New
York City about two weeks ago and have
been drinking from the proverbial fire
hose so to speak on both the job in the
city itself standard disclaimer going
into this everything here is my own view
nothing to represent the administration
executive office of the president
Microsoft although Celeste I do want to
issue a personal apology for your
PowerPoint issues we'll see what we can
do about all right presidential
innovation fellows briefly just to give
you a little bit of background tap the
piff program as we call it was started
in 2012 by Todd Park Todd Park was the
second CTO of the United States as
appointed by President Obama the whole
idea was to see if they could bring
private sector expertise and experience
into the federal government and sort of
cycle people through on six-month
one-year tours of duty to get folks from
Silicon Valley and other parts of
Industry to come bring best practices to
government and sort of infuse it with
modern ways of thinking and
methodologies really nice shout out
earlier from Justin who spoke about what
they're what they're working on at
Commerce about our program appreciate
him mentioning that I what he neglected
to tell you was that so jeff chen the
chief data scientist of commerce who use
data to find the optimal place to take a
photo of the sky he was a former
presidential innovation fellow and the
midas program that he mentioned which he
should check out it's really a pretty
awesome website in program they've got
going that was created by two of my
colleagues and the
program so with trying to leave our
fingerprints everywhere actually 11
brief statistic on that so there's been
roughly 120 presidential innovation
fellows since the inception of the
program five four or five years ago I
think last year they had an eighty
percent retention rate folks that stayed
on in federal government and some
capacity so that's something that we
like to talk about I get the question a
lot so i'll mention it briefly what's
going to happen after the administration
changes to this program and other
programs like the u.s. digital service
18f these other things you might have
heard about speaking for the
presidential innovation program
specifically were pretty confident and
excited in the future of the program the
president's issued an executive order
for my plump formally establishing its
presence about nine months ago and then
roughly six to eight weeks ago the House
passed a bill almost unanimously all
four hundred something representatives
except for eight voted to do the same to
formally establish this program through
legislation so and that was actually
sponsored by the majority leader
McCarthy on on the right side of the
aisle so very excited about we've been
able to accomplish and maintain our sort
of bipartisan nature this graphic i just
threw in there because i think it
represents us nicely the whole idea is
everybody coming together from different
backgrounds different experiences
different walks of life different
sectors to do what we can for the
American people so primarily what we're
gonna be talking about today is a
project that I worked on called the
opportunity project during my time as as
a fellow and let me see I wrote too many
notes and they're scrolling off the
screen there we go so the opportunity
project was is this initiative that we
launched last March to basically spur
the creation of private and nonprofit
sector digital tools based on federal
and local open data that help
communities find information about
resources needed to thrive such as the
affordable housing as affordable housing
quality schools and jobs so three main
goals for this we're basically at number
one access to opportunity for people
that need it opportunity is a admittedly
vague and overload
term in this case it basically means the
things that the ability for actually as
the president puts it the ability for a
young person's destiny not to be
determined by her zip code but by the
scope of her dreams and the strength of
her work ethic so the number one goal of
this was really to empower people to
that end the second goal a tangential
goal through way of implementation was
to increase the accessibility of federal
data and I'll talk a little bit about
that and then the thing that I'm really
passionate about there was a third goal
was to leverage collaboration across
different sectors to actually accomplish
this and I'll talk about a bit about
that as well no technology should be
considered radical or transformative
unless it impacts every single person
I'm assuming everybody here knows who DJ
Patil is needs no intro chief data
scientist of the United States the
person actually turns out who is
credited with coining the term data
science I love this quotation he says it
all the time in the White House and I
think it really helps remind us that I
mean I can I've got an app that will get
me a locally sourced kale salad with
corn fredburger on a gluten-free bun
delivered here in about 20 minutes right
we've got technology for everything
we've got technological edge venture
capitals let's set it but we've got all
the startups in Silicon Valley or the
majority of them right now are like
being created to replace young
technologists and mothers to do their
laundry for them to get them food this
for me really really brings me back home
to to what we can do with technology
what we should be doing with technology
to illustrate that I'd love to introduce
you to Briona Rogers Briona this is a
photo from the March 7th the launch of
this event that we had at the White
House and her story is really remarkable
um a few years ago she was just a single
mom living the shelter and she had a new
baby she could she commuted eight hours
by bus every day with a newborn in the
shelter today she's she's really pulled
herself up by her bootstraps she is
pursuing an accounting degree she lives
in her own home with a 10-minute walk to
her job
and so you look at folks that are in
this sort of position and you think to
yourself you know how can we help them
with technology and how can we help them
specifically with data President Obama
is very much a data oriented president I
love this quotation by him understanding
and innovating with data has the
potential to change the way we do almost
anything for the better so the whole
thought for this was can we reach out to
these people that are in such situations
can we partner with people that know a
lot about them civil society subject
matter experts not NGO leaders and bring
the the wood behind the arrow and the
power of the federal government's
convening and match it up with folks at
the private sector who have all this
muscle and talent and can actually
implement things that people could then
use and get everybody together and sort
of convene and bring together an effort
to help folks like Brianna out so open
to the history of open data and actually
let me back a little bit so it was
mentioned earlier that under this
administration we've had the the project
open data initiative we've had the
executive order of 2013 OMB xem 13 13
for any walks in the audience memorandum
basically saying that the oak the
default for government data should be
that it's open and there's machine
readable so lots of efforts this is sort
of in my mind been the progression of
those efforts so the first step has been
so permission you need to fear an agency
and you've got a whole bunch of data
locked up you need the legal authority
you need to read make sure you're not
leaking publicly that they're private
excuse me PII personally identify
information you want to make sure that
you you have to actually have the
authority to release these datasets get
that done clear with your comms your
legal team and everything so that
happened in the early days that's been
done step two is publication actually
releasing us data after you've got the
legal authority to do it how do you
actually get this into the hands of
folks in the public that actually has
its own I could put some sub bullets in
there because some people you need or
some agencies were able to essentially
check that box like yes we are
compliance here is a PDF of all of our
data
great it's a great first step difficult
to do something with as a technologist
rate so after that it was okay PDF is
wonderful let's make it machine readable
I like right here's a CSV file of all of
our data it's like awesome that's what
that's a fantastic evolution what about
if somebody wants to be able to ping it
in real-time receive real-time updates
could we do something with an API on it
oh sure absolutely here's a here's a
rust here's a you know an xml-based soap
api that we created like super all right
we're getting in the right direction but
how about taking it a step further and
so it's really evolved to the point
where today if you look at David go for
example there are numerous restful api s
that have all kinds of data and
wonderful documentation behind them step
three though and this is where this
effort really comes in is accessibility
there's so much government data hundreds
of thousands of datasets is it findable
is it usable is anybody using I was my
friend my colleague dan hammer likes to
say if if a data set has opened up and
known as around does it make a sound so
we took that to heart and looking at
data.gov if you've got and data back it
was fantastic by the way Phil ashlock
runs this program and he is actually
another former presidential innovation
fellow date about gov has is you see
that 180 6605 data sets on it awesome
everybody in this room here probably has
a great idea of how to use all that data
what if you don't what if you what if
you're not well versed in our what if
you don't know what Hadoop is or you
know I'm a producer any of these
heavyweight technologies but maybe
you're really good with excel and you
are a community leader you're a policy
advisor and you want to look into some
of these data sets on a particular issue
our thought was what if we could sort of
curate and i love that steven thank you
for mentioning curation so heavily this
morning because i think it really speaks
to the heart of kind of again the third
wave of data accessibility here can we
curate datasets around around a
particular subject area or an issue and
offer them up and sort of say here if
you're interested in this if you're
interested in
environmental issues or if you're
interested in police use of force so if
you're interested in this case
opportunity here are some starting
points there's so much data across
different agencies that maybe we can
offer them up on a silver platter and
say just start here and maybe here are
some tools that you can use to access on
what not out of all of that was that was
born the opportunity project so so
curation and being better student
stewards of our own data is is a big
part of it if you go to our website
you'll see this you can expand each one
of these so there's federal data within
each one of those you've got different
agencies within each agency you've got
numerous data sets so along these lines
you'll see a lot from census obviously
the American Community Survey the
decennial surveys you can imagine bureau
of labor statistics you can imagine I
mean what else impacts opportunity what
else effects this you can imagine the
location of bus lines so the Department
of Transportation has a hand in this and
then we talked to different
organizations at the local levels and
state levels and and partnered with
cities that have a really great robust
open data program already in place and
we added their data and to be it turns
out there's there's a lot in the local
data sets that we don't know as a
federal government for example some of
some of those transportation lines we
don't know where they are we don't know
where grocery stores are in Minneapolis
but some of the cities have actually
taken it upon themselves to create those
data sets and release them so we put all
this data in one place we got a lot of
folks together and the result has been
initially 12 teams that worked on this
so that was really some in March of this
year 12 tools and then in addition to
the tools that were created at roughly
in close to a hundred different
commitments that were made to this end
you can go to opportunity census gov and
play with all these yourself but it
really speaks to DJ patil quote by the
way my presentation is really just like
half quotes of other smart people saying
things
well jeez advanced data science is a
team sport love this quote every time we
have a conference call for this effort
there were probably 80 90 people because
we had federal government and this leads
into my next slide we had so
collaboration across the federal
government so within the White House
you've got the Department of we had
offensive science and technology policy
you have Domestic Policy Council you've
got OMB and then even outside of the
White House across the federal
government we working with census and
commerce and housing and urban
development and health and human
services and that's just within the
federal government if you look in
government in general got federal and
then we were going across government and
partnering with state and local
governments and if you put the public
sector side and look even more broadly
cross sector we had public sector
private sector who were sort of the
builders and the muscle behind all of
this who actually essentially donated
time on behalf of the organization's to
put their developers I have to empower
their developers to work on some of
these issues and create things and then
civil society civil society being the
NGOs and the subject matter experts and
community advocates the people on the
ground were really really close to these
issues and really know and their
communities you know what is actually
affecting people we got them all
together and the whole thought was to
really go to users affect the products
that users are already using and this is
where I kind of get philosophical in a
limited way about government and that
government should not be building apps
we should be creating a platform for
other folks to do the things that they
want to do with these resources hundreds
of millions of people already use these
products right and these are household
brands everybody knows them why why
would we create a new app that is going
to go into the App Store and no one's
ever going to download like it just
doesn't make sense so the thought was
can we partner with them can we
encourage them and give them the
resources to modify their existing
products and platforms such that the
people that are already using them can
then benefit from them in new ways that
they may not have thought over may not
be directly impactful to their bottom
line so we did that and again here are
some of the tools that came out of it
and so I'll walk you through a few of
them this one's by red
anybody's redfin so redfin basically
created what they call opportunity score
so when you're looking for housing on
their website now they have taken a
number of these data sets that we
suggested could be used to the end of to
the end that we want to accomplish
blended them together to create their
own sort of proprietary opportunity
score which in this case you can see is
a blend of healthcare financial aid
insurance retail trade accommodation and
food services and you can put in any zip
code in the country and it will give you
a heat map sort of describing the
opportunity and their demos they put in
they use the dress of the White House
and it always comes up as opportunity
score 100 which is kind of fun so we
love that this one is by as a vs jose
via i created this tool called transit
analysis i think it's a super cool you
can now you can basically put in any
location and it will show you within 30
minutes of public transportation
everywhere you can get locations
reachable from 30 minutes here and then
you can overlay on that certain points
of interest that you're interested in so
here you can see the corner store access
percentile and this particular geography
is fifty-eight percent and this one you
can see that it goes down to 41 percent
and the recreation recreation center
access index is for you know so if if
you have somebody if you have a child
that's interested in playing basketball
this is probably not the place for you
this tool is by policy map and this
takes it sort of to the next level of
personalization and allows you to put in
which aspects of opportunity allows you
to define opportunity yourself so in
this case you can see there they're
choosing housing schools and
transportation and then visualizing the
location of ideal ideal areas for that
so pops up on a map hey according to the
things that you care about these are
some areas that you might be like might
be interested in looking at
geographically and then you can search
for an address and identify amenities in
an area so you can you know most of
these do tend to have a local and
geographic flavor to them which is why
many of them
relate on maps and those tend to be some
of the partners that that created the
strongest tools this one I really love
from great schools they created a sort
of proprietary but open ranking based on
demographic for how schools do so a
Secretary penny Pritzker his photo you
saw the Secretary of Commerce this
morning she has this wonderful quote so
Noah as a part of of commerce and and
she's fond of saying nobody in the
nobody cares about the average weather
in the in America right it's like
depends on what Souter and obviously so
I think that's really applicable here
because if you if you just look at plane
rankings for schools it doesn't isolate
so it doesn't necessarily illuminate the
fact that for example in this school
asian students have a seventy-six
percent average test score where's
Hispanic students have a thirty-six
percent Cesc were so it really allows
you to sort of personalized what
personalized what you're looking for
another example of that here the other
one that I'll mention is this is
fantastic streetwise are based out of
Oakland California so every blue dot on
this map here is in an official data set
suggested to be a grocery store as
reported by the county what streetwise
does is what they call ground truthing
and when they ground truth this turns
out most of those our liquor stores that
happen to sell bananas they might be
corner source of cell Twinkies and
roughly what I made twenty percent maybe
twenty five percent of those the green
dots are actually bona fide grocery
stores so it gives you a flavor of some
of the tools that have come out of this
that we're really excited about the
switch gears briefly and tell you a
little bit about what we're doing at
Microsoft because they're limey to be
here today and I do think it's actually
relevant to this effort great song
no problem so i don't know if i turned
my not so we're doing a lot of things
related to so i'm on a team that is
called technology and civic innovation
in new york city or small to you we've
got five folks to rotating fellows and
three full-time right now we're in six
cities across the country New York
Boston Chicago Seattle San Francisco and
San Jose and so we've got about 10
people working on this effort nationwide
and what we do is we look at ways to
marry up Microsoft's products platforms
brand recognition resources with the
needs of these various local communities
and very broadly to find see how we can
make life better for people in those
cities so one thing that we've done we
partner with data kinds familiar with
data kind the kinds an awesome
organization you haven't heard of them
their mission is literally to i think
it's it's used data science for
humanitarian good something along those
lines and so they will partner with
organizations that have tons of data
like Red Cross for example but don't
necessarily have resources to employ
their own data scientists and so they
worked with Red Cross to say hey let's
use some smart data to figure out where
the likelihood of smoke detectors smoke
detector emissions might be across the
country and they launched a campaign
based on that to go install smoke
detectors of different areas we're
partnering with data kind to further
what's called vision zero vision zero is
an effort to reduce the number of
traffic fatalities that happen every
year anybody want to guess how many
pedestrians and cyclists get injured by
cars in new york city every year
shoutout number
250,000 it's an aggressive number you've
lived in New York it's not at 16,000 but
still if you do the math that's every
half hour somebody's on foot or on a
bike is getting nailed by a car that's
crazy so in 2014 mayor de Blasio brought
this effort that was started in Sweden
called vision zero to adapt it to New
York and the goal is to reduce that
number by fifty percent by 2020 and so
we thought well how can we apply data
science to this and so we partnered with
data kind and we've enabled a fellow to
be looking into this full time he's
pulling data from the state in the city
department transportation from all kinds
of other datasets many public some
private or proprietary and the thought
is you know if you wanted to if you as a
city wanted to put in twenty slows on
somewhere where should you do it and can
we help you that's a paraphrase one of
the earlier speakers do that any
data-driven way rather than kind of by
gut feel or anecdote anecdote not
equaling data as we all know there were
two hundred thirty deaths in New York
City relate to this last year and so
we're excited about this effort that one
thing has come out of it so far as the
the general speed has been reduced the
speed limit it's been reduced from 30
miles an hour to 25 miles an hour in the
city and so we're trying to think about
how we can how we can enact policy smart
policy and changes going forward and
then also look backwards and say okay
what are we done and what can we can we
tell whether or not some of these things
are actually working so that's one thing
that we're doing another we're doing is
um turns out forty-nine percent of
people in New York City speak something
other than english at home I'm sorry do
not exclusively speak English at home
forty-nine percent are polyglots
essentially so Microsoft turns out has a
cloud-based translation service how can
we take that condition and take this
resource and marry them up so we're
looking at partnering with public
schools deaf and hard-of-hearing
students ESL students and potentially
other programs to see how we might be
able to make life better for those folks
we've also got a protocol Civic graph
that we created our fellows working on
this Briana vecchione and it's
essentially taking a lot of people are
in the public good space in the Civic
tech space and I can be a little bit
overwhelming what companies are donating
their time to this what little startups
are working on what NGOs exist what
funders you've got you know the Ford
Foundation all these
folks robin hood that are pouring money
to this and it can be kind of hard to
get your head around it at least for me
so the idea here is to try and get lots
of data into that and then be able to
visualize it and makes more sense of it
we've got roughly think eight or nine
hundred data points in there so far and
the relationships between them and it's
mobile-friendly most recently we opened
actually yesterday a space in New York
City called the reactor which is
something that we can use to have
convenience for people that want to run
events so this was a few nights ago this
was with the United Nation United
Nations was in town so we partnered with
them and un women and the Malala fund to
hold an event there Malala unfortunately
couldn't make it she's in high demand
but we had some wonderful dialogues
about the stressors on folks who are
refugees from all kinds of places Syria
Egypt other countries we heard
first-hand from from the woman there in
the very front and center who's got the
the gold and black headscarf on who
mother whose mother was sold her whole
life that she didn't need an education
because women just get married her mom
got married at fourteen years old so we
try to basically in this case it was a
convening between our group Microsoft's
public policy group the United Nations
folks this nonprofit mall and basically
bring folks together and have a dialogue
about how we can how come where we can
affect change for the better so one of
my favorite quotes was stolen earlier
but I'm gonna do it anyway this was the
president at South by Southwest this
year made history by appearing at South
by Southwest for the first time and he
really did say I'm here to recruit all
of you and and so next where I go with
this just until my quote but it's
fantastic good quote if you're not
potentially politically inclined or
inspired by President Obama anybody
recognize this gentleman came and Dean
came in absolutely famous for inventing
the Segway also just a fantastic
humanitarian insulin pumps prosthetic
limbs clean water at the pleasure of
watching him receive the simplest photos
from him receiving a global humanitarian
award for his work on creating clean
water in 2013 at the tech Wars in
Silicon Valley during his acceptance
speech she stood up there and by the way
this is a black-tie event everybody else
was in you know full tuxedo and
everything he gets up there and and in
his fantastic casual denim and it looks
at the audience and he says what do I
say to a room full of so much
low-hanging fruit he said you you folks
are the people that have the economic
resources the money the tech know-how
and the passion to actually be able to
impact many of my programs and I was
reminded of that when I was trying to
put this presentation together and
realizing that was going to be up here
in front of folks that are some of the
most brilliant minds in data science
what can I say to a roomful of
low-hanging fruit and so my plea and
what I'll leave you with is to consider
potentially being inspired by some of
the stories and some of the participants
in the opportunity project so far
hopefully that our work Microsoft can we
don't want to be the only ones doing
this we want everybody to be doing this
every Enterprise every startup to be
sort of making Civic civically minded
Lee how can you use your own expertise
how can your company incorporate into
its products that already have a user
base features that might be beneficial
to them particularly if they are some of
them the Americans that may need the
most help and final thought on that is
that keep an eye out in early October
we're releasing 25 new tools there are a
number of organizations are part of the
second cohort they're working with six
federal agencies this time on curated
use cases including major universities
that are modifying their curricula lots
of cool stuff is coming to come out of
this the date is still somewhat in flux
but look for an announcement early
October from the White House yeah thank
you so much
you